so i've been playing outriders since
release and i'm honestly quite surprised
to explain firstly i want to thank
square enix for providing me the
opportunity to play a little bit earlier
than the rest of the world so
thank you for that outriders is a looter
shooter this means that the inevitable
gameplay loop of the game will be
doing missions and getting loot maybe
the occasional modding and crafting here
and there but then repeats back to
shooting then looting
accompanying this loop are both main and
side quests that give you xp
loot and small parts of the game's
overall lore but most games with this
gameplay loop the quests are tedious
boring or just a complete drag making
you question whether doing these is even
worth the xp
or if you just push onto the main quest
and enjoy something of the story
this can hinder the overall experience
but outriders capitalizes on this
from the start the developers have
talked about how passionate they are to
create a world filled with rich stories
and i think they've nailed it so far
ingame is a tab called journal which is
a large codex of laura to read up on
this houses all sorts of journal entries
from important events to what seems like
meaningless articles this is split into
many different categories from npcs to
enemies to the overall world itself
a good example of this is in the first
tab this is where all the people you
come across
are located in the journal is more
important characters like jakob someone
who
sticks with you throughout most of the
game making him an important character
to a vendor named mr chang who dies
within 10 seconds of a side quest in
fact the side quest isn't even really
about him he's a side character
and a side quest yet he has an entry in
the journal and he isn't the only one
there there's tons of characters like
this who make it seconds of screen time
but
get an entry dedicated to them to add to
this sometimes you may be introduced to
a character very early in the game maybe
through a vision or a word of mouth this
can then add an entry but later you may
encounter that character face to face
which adds a separate line to the text
as your character is writing new entries
as their journey continues
this is shown in malik a character who
is briefly mentioned in conversation
quite early in the game
thanks to this dialogue there was a new
entry in the journal but after our
encounter with him face to face we got a
new section added to his already added
entry meaning that just because there's
an entry for a character
doesn't mean it's fully completed
there's a ton of side quests in this
game that catalog all the diaries and
journals we uncover like the ones
previously mentioned allowing us to
learn about the side quests we do so
that it doesn't feel like we're only
doing this to see the experience bar go
higher we're also learning about the
motives and beliefs of the characters we
meet to further go in depth on what's
happening we need to discuss how things
got the way they are in outriders this
is technically a spoiler warning but
this is roughly the first hour of the
game so it's not going to ruin your
experience if you hear this before
playing outriders takes place on a
fictional planet called enoch the earth
is beyond repair so for the human
species to survive we have to start over
on a new planet we're on board one of
the two ships that would take the
population to a new planet and after 83
years enoch is where they landed
we are a group of people called
outriders an advanced vanguard who is
helping the colonization of enoch they
are a small part of a much bigger
organization called the eca or the enoch
colonization authority
upon landing we can see the true beauty
of this planet it looks quite like earth
so it's a perfect place to start life
all over again after a quick tutorial
we're sent to find a probe signal and
enoch's true form appears
enoch has a very deadly storm called the
anomaly that melts anyone
in seconds one of the members of the eca
maxwell
is insistent on calling the flores the
large ship we're a part of saying it's
okay to come down
even with the storm being present in the
area that ship houses 500 000 people so
lots of people are going to be unaware
of the dangers enoch really has
we get injured during this exchange and
are thrown into cryos that we don't die
right away but awake 31 years in the
future to see enoch turned into a war
zone we're then dragged through the
insurgent zone filled with captives and
dead bodies hanging from the ceiling
we see that nothing has changed enoch is
just like earth and we're fighting each
other over the little resources we have
left the guy who rides with us in the
back of the truck explains that the
world went to [ __ ] quite fast and then
all the eca members relaxed while the
rest of the population starved which is
what started the war we're then engulfed
by the anomaly but only on rare
occasions a person may live the anomaly
this then makes them altered beings able
to turn the tides of battle due to
supernatural powers which allow them to
heal deadly injuries and give them
powers no one else has
this starts our journey throughout the
game's world uncovering its secrets and
helping others along the way
one thing that is quite interesting is
the multiple encounters we see that are
similar to the intro
in the early areas of the game we come
across a soldier who is injured she
points us towards a captain that is in
charge of the group ahead of us and the
one who injured her when we defeat him
we get a quick cut scene between us
and the captain you're an altar
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
why the [ __ ] are you fighting for those
those
fascist [ __ ]
weird ones fighting for our lives
do you even know what they did to us
i know what you did to me
this conversation brings up two good
points why are we fighting for shira the
eca and the others and who really is the
bad guys
this game is the complete opposite of
destiny to me now i haven't played much
destiny but to my knowledge the
guardians are considered the good guys
they always have been and i don't recall
any guardians who fight against the
people of the tower and the traveler
like i said
maybe i'm wrong but it's still quite
obvious that there are either no
guardians or only a handful or so that
are considered evil whereas the altered
can do as they please
they don't need to listen to people as
they are stronger than normal humans by
a lot
i understand this game is a looter
shooter so betraying shira and jakob and
everyone else may [ __ ] up some
replayable quests but it does make you
wonder why are characters taking orders
we can do as we please people literally
see the altered beings as gods
the other question was about who really
are the bad guys captain reiner mentions
that he
like many others were segregated from
everyone and were just fighting for
their lives while the rest lived
peacefully just like the guy in the
intro
they were left out to dry while the eca
lived comfortably so
who really is at fault for all this it
makes the story more compelling than a
simple we are good guy and we stop
bad guy storyline our character does
start to take notice of these powers and
kind of uses them a bit to his advantage
later in certain areas as we're tasked
with finding this person's squad who
ended up becoming workers under a guy
named corrigan
he's surprised as corrigan is a ruthless
ruler and we
kind of just killed his guys so he's
definitely not going to be happy with us
he asks us once again to help him and
says to not mention his name to corrigan
or he could get killed our character
doesn't care and
just asks for his reward and then leaves
what exactly is the guy going to do
shoot us
considering the fact that we're altered
and we just fought dozens of enemies at
once and lived
this guy can't do anything to us we as
altered are essentially free beings we
don't have to fall
in line with what an organization tells
us to do because we can easily kill
their organization in one night
this not only justifies the player's
power fantasy but makes us question
certain actions like why are we on this
side of the war or why are we fighting
at all
the existence of the altered is truly a
fantastic plot device for the story
besides the altered and their mere
existence being an excellent plot the
side quests are just as captivating
i'll only share a few as to not spoil
all the wonderful side content this game
provides but our first quest is given to
us by a person named alfred mckellen
he's an old man just staring at the
sunset while not even down the road are
harmful creatures that could kill us
he wants to go back to his house but
insurgents are blocking the path it's
simple stuff
until we make it to his house it's
ransacked completely destroyed
outside is anna mckellen's journal
alfred's wife the journal talks about
how the eca reduced everyone's ration
so people are starving alfred had been
trading favors with their supervisors to
get more mres for his family the
townspeople started noticing something
was wrong is alfred's kids had lots more
energy than their kids did thanks to all
the meals they've been eating
people started spreading rumors about
the couple and anna wanted alfred to
stop getting those extra rations as it
could make things worse for their family
alfred didn't listen and he was stealing
even more food the settlement decided
to call a meeting about this issue we
could see the aftermath of this meeting
once alfred arrives as three graves are
outside his house
for his wife and his two kids alfred
explains what we read in the journal he
just wanted to protect and feed his kids
he didn't care about the house or the
equipment and he just wanted to see his
family's graves once again so we grant
his wish and we leave him so he can sit
in peace with his family it makes the
player question what they would do in a
situation like this
even in established and organized
settlements like this one on this world
that's kill or be killed so would you
deprive others of food if it meant your
family could eat
another tragic story occurs about two or
three areas later we meet an old
crippled war veteran he and his daughter
are separated from one another as they
fight for opposing sides this isn't
uncommon on enoch as many families have
been split from one another only to be
able to reunite on the battlefield this
older man howard is lucky enough that he
doesn't have to experience that as he
and his daughter have been exchanging
notes with one another using a smuggler
that travels from zone to zone but the
smuggler has gone dark recently we need
to make sure the letter and his daughter
are okay as we follow the path we
overhear a conversation between two
people we discover his daughter has been
dead the whole time and that the
smuggler has been writing notes to him
as his daughter the smuggler has always
believed that the truth was better than
lying no matter how brutal the truth may
be
but after what happened to her own
family she wouldn't dare see another
family go through what she went through
so she was playing the role of this
man's daughter so he doesn't have to
experience the pain of loss considering
his daughter is all he has left
as she dies she gives us her last note
saying that it's one of her better ones
we then give the letter to him and say
that she and the letter are okay
and safe was this truly the best choice
though should we have told him the truth
so that he wasn't being lied to or was
it better to have him die knowing his
daughter is alive and well
even if she's really not honestly it's
one of the best early game side quests
this game has
our last two are just a little bit
different as it's more behind the scenes
on people affected by the anomaly or the
altered beings
according to a woman named jocelyn her
men have been disappearing one after
another because they've been hearing
voices
as we get closer to the source of the
voices we see it's an altered being
preaching about the anomaly earlier i
said that the altered are revered by
some as gods these soldiers clearly
can't compete against an altered so
they're praying to him begging for
forgiveness and to be cleansed the
altered person clearly is enjoying this
and playing the role they gave him as he
preaches about being children of the
anomaly we can see someone who is a
non-believer in the faith and because of
this was cast out and vaporized by the
anomaly
saying to the members that the anomaly
was embracing this person and accepting
them as one of their own
just like they all hoped to be accepted
by the anomaly too one day we could see
that these members are so brainwashed
that even after their leader was killed
they now see us as the new leader since
we're also altered a little bit later we
get another quest similar to this we are
sent to investigate someone called the
alchemist the alchemist is an
altered being who experiments on people
he's also notorious amongst both sides
of the war so much so that
neither have made contact with him ever
throughout the lab we get four different
journal entries that explain the whole
story
the alchemist has been experimenting on
human prisoners his first experiments
were fastening people to poles so that
they could be makeshift lightning rods
on an effort to explain the alteration
process the altered beings go through
the eca cut funding from his experiments
as they planned on using the prisoners
to exchange them for their own soldiers
captured by the insurgents and for the
obvious reason his experiments are a
little less than humane
one thing that is quite relevant to the
alchemist is that he calls the
alteration a curse
unlike many who seem to be enjoying
their supernatural powers
he doesn't seem to the alchemist was
continuing his experiments for years
tying people up to poles as the storms
approached so he could gather more
information and data one
subject of his number six was showing
promise as he was able to use his
altered powers to spawn flames from the
ground he is hopeful that if he runs
more tests he can remove his altered
state an excerpt at the bottom of the
note says that every day he grows closer
and closer to purging this cursed
infection from his body
sadly in journal 3 we see that it may
not be as easy as he thought as
subject-6 is growing more and more
hatred for him every day later that day
he was searching for more test subjects
and he came across a lone soldier in a
field
out of instinct he busted his head open
which caused all of his blood to pour
everywhere the alchemist hadn't felt
this way before
finally understanding the true power of
the altered as he didn't want to kill
him but he felt like he needed to
two more soldiers approached looking for
their lost friend who met the same fate
he ends the note with all this time i've
been searching for a weapon to destroy
the altered
what if i'm that weapon the alchemist in
his last entry is clearly confused
and upset realizing that he just killed
someone on a whim having no regard for
their life what's worse is that subjects
has escaped and it's only a matter of
time until he finds him we see what
happened after as a vision appears
showing subject 6 impale the alchemist
and leave his laboratory
something very interesting of note is
that without this quest you may not
understand who malik is
from both the cutscene and visions it's
clear this is the same person so now we
understand
molok's hatred for the world and why he
uses his altered powers to kill people
it's a nice side quest that not only
tells a compelling story about one
person but
also the origin story for a villain we
face in game this is just a taste of
some of the side quests the game has to
offer and i did not cherry pick these
quests
these were all located within the first
five or so areas of the game
and i still have a long way to go before
i beat this game's story as according to
some media sources there's around maybe
12 to 17 areas in the game to explore
which means
i have dozens of more side quests i
haven't even experienced yet
if you do want to get this game for
yourself it is playable on console and
pc
i would always highly recommend watching
reviews of gameplay and other mechanics
as this video has only showed
little of its story and not much else
but if you are dead set on getting this
game at the time of making this video
it's on pc playstation and xbox for
60 dollars or for free if you own xbox
game pass
outriders is an interesting game i
didn't think i was going to like this
game as looter shooters have never been
a genre i dump hours into but these
small side quests have pulled me in
enough to keep me going
something i did not expect to happen as
you wind down to the outro i want to
thank you all for joining me on this
journey while we look through some of
outrider's beautifully crafted side
quests and characters
if you want to see some more analysis or
essay style content like this i highly
recommend my recent uploads like
dishonored and the extreme power dynamic
between the rich and poor throughout the
series as well as my far cry upload
showcasing why far cry's villains are so
likable and well written
as always like the video and subscribe
if you're new if you're a returning
viewer i thank you for coming back for
another analysis video
thank you for watching and goodbye
[Music]
you